I'll be reviewing my Claude SEO
automation that got this website over
70,000 total web clicks and averaging
over 1,000 clicks every single day.
Let's go ahead and get started. Step one
is we need to do an audit. We need to
know where we are from an SEO
perspective from on-page, off-page,
technical SEO, and so on. So, in order
to do that, I had to do it manually, but
now I've actually go went ahead and
created a skill for you. So, if you
enter in the skill, the skill will take
care of everything that you need to do
to get a comprehensive SEO audit for any
site in any niche. So, we can see here
in our audit we'll get a bunch of useful
information and actionable steps that we
need to take. If you want to get access
to all of the prompts and the SOPs in
today's video, just comment SEO below
and I'll send you over this site that
I've created that has all of the SOPs
that you can simply follow, plug it into
Claude, and get started. So, first you
need to do an SEO audit. And in this SEO
audit, we're going to get a competitor
analysis, we're going to get critical
fixes that we need to do right away,
we're going to get an on-page SEO audit,
we're also going to get keyword
opportunities, we're going to get a
content strategy,
we're going to get schema markup, and
we're also going to get a technical SEO
audit that will help us with our page
speed insights and our responsiveness of
our website. Also, backlink
intelligence, so on and so forth with a
90-day action plan. So, now we know the
key things that we need to improve on
our website. Now, if you are using
WordPress, then you will have to
obviously go ahead and manually do this,
but I've actually went ahead and showed
you guys on this channel already how to
build a website using Claude code or
using tools like Bolt
to create indexable, rankable websites
that you can simply use AI to make these
changes. If you want to see that video,
again comment SEO below and I'll include
that within the workflow. So, as you can
see this site here that I created is
completely AI generated. So, I can go
over to Cloud Code and if I went ahead
and I found the things that I need to
improve upon, like the
critical issues here, I can simply go
ahead copy over all of the things that I
need to improve upon,
pop it into the AI and the AI will do it
automatically for me. I think that's the
future of website building and it saves
you a ton of time. You can also do that
for your on-page elements, for your
title, for your meta description, so on
and so forth. So, now that we know where
we are at in terms of SEO and we've went
ahead and made the changes for on-page,
off-page, and technical SEO, now it's
time to focus on improving our E-E-A-T.
It's essentially the trustworthiness or
the ranking or the trust factors that
Google has for our website. And to do
so, we need to improve the content on
our website. Google needs to look at our
website as
a thought leader and as a pillar for
your specific niche. So again, if I
scroll down to our SEO audit, I will be
able to get some keyword opportunities
and I also get a content strategy. So,
we can see here we get a bunch of
different articles that we can start
writing on directly. So, when it comes
to content, I would say that there's two
different types of content that you'll
create in order to bring you more
organic traffic. One is going to be blog
post and if you are a local business,
the second is going to be service pages.
So, if you do different services like
plumbing, then you would have a page
about emergency plumbing,
commercial plumbing, condominium
plumbing, plumbing, whatever services
you do, you would need to have service
pages for that. And if you are a local
business within specific areas, then I
would have local area specific. So, for
example, emergency plumbing in Toronto,
emergency plumbing in
Niagara, emergency plumbing in Brampton,
whatever state or whatever space or
whatever city you service, you would
also want to go ahead and create a
service page for that specific city. And
if you combine those two different types
of content, then you will have a very
comprehensive website that will 100%
start ranking as you scale out your
content writing. So, in today's video,
I'll be showing you how to set up your
automated content writing calendar.
Instead of having to do it manually, we
can set up an automation that writes
content for us on a daily basis. To get
this set up, we need to connect WordLift
to our Claude quote. In order to do
that, we need to get a plan for
WordLift. Once we have a paid plan on
WordLift, we can now connect our MCP.
So, if I head over to MCP here and I
scroll all the way down,
I'll be able to see how to connect my
MCP. Right, so we have the instructions
right here on WordLift. And essentially,
what that does is WordLift is a content
writing tool. So, it'll write your
articles for you. It'll be SEO
optimized. It'll have images. It'll be
indexable. It'll have your site map and
all of your uh brand voice if you
include it. So, if you haven't set up
your website on WordLift, it's very,
very easy to do so. You just have head
over to brand voice and knowledge. You
set up your brand voice and your
knowledge. And if you want to connect
over and have internal linking, head
over to settings, general site maps, and
then you want to add in our site map
here. And then WordLift will pull the
best URLs for internal linking.
So, once that is all set up on WordLift,
we just have to head back over to
Claude. And again, to get it connected,
head over to settings.
We're going to go to connectors. We're
going to go to customize.
Then we're going to go to
add, add a custom connector, name
WordLift.
And then the URL is going to be
wordliftapi.com.
And then we just simply add it over. And
And WordLift will be added over to our
Claude. So now we can tell Claude to do
anything we want it to do and then it
will execute that task in WordRocket. So
again, going under our article content
calendar, I'm going to copy over this
first article. I'm going to tell it to
use WordRocket to write this article,
use web search mode,
include three images,
and add
geo optimization.
Right? So essentially, what that's going
to do is it's going to then write the
article. And if I've actually went ahead
and connected my WordPress site, I can
tell
WordRocket to then
post this to my site.
Right? And it will write the article and
post it directly over to my site. Now,
to take this a step further, I can then
go ahead and create a schedule task that
does this on a day-to-day basis. And
this is how you can automate your
content writing using Claude. You don't
have to do anything. You create a
schedule task that happens every single
day at 9:00 a.m. You give it the topics
and it'll go through and write those
topics for you on a day-to-day basis.
So while that's generating, the next
skill in which we will be using is
ensuring our website is AI search ready
and that it's actually going to be
mentioned in ChatGPT and other AI
search. So to do this, I've used another
skill which is called our AI search
ranking SOP. So this SOP allows us to
get our brand mentioned in ChatGPT,
Perplexity, Google AI overview, and just
ensuring that our website is AI search
ready. So again, I went ahead and popped
this into Claude, and here is our AI
search overview. So we see here our
overview compared to our competitors,
and we see what we need to do in order
to improve this. So we can see here that
this is almost entirely a content
problem. So this website has 0% AI
visibility, which is like most new
websites. And this is what we need to do
in order to ensure we'll be able to rank
on AI search. Where we're missing AI
citations, we're seeing
analysis, content gap analysis, or AI
gap analysis with our top competitors.
Really, really actionable and useful
information. So geo-optimized topic
roadmap roadmap, so I can see here
topics that we can write about that will
actually
be
mentioned on AI search, right? So we see
here this is really, really good
insights here that we can then pop
into Claude again and tell it to use
WordRocket to write the article, right?
And again, you can set this on a
schedule as well. So we see the first
article that we pushed over actually was
able to generate and it was able to post
over to the actual website itself. So we
click
if we open up this link here, we'll be
able to see the article that was
created, generated, and posted over to
the site here. So we can see here that
you can automate this pretty easily
using these different skills in Claude
and using some connectors like
WordRocket to generate your content for
you. And again, we can do the same thing
for the geo article. We can copy over
this article and tell Claude to now
write this article um following the
instructions and post it over to our
site. But if we head back over to
WordRocket, we can see that the full
article with images has been generated.
So sometimes you need to tell the AI to
give it a little bit to make sure
everything has been generated and then
go over and post it over to your site.
But as you can see, you get a full
article here, right? so we can just walk
down the list here and send it over to
Claude and Claude will then go ahead and
generate the articles using WordRocket.
So you can see here you have a full
automated process that allows you to get
the best SEO metrics and then set up
automations that will improve your SEO
and it also set up automations that will
create a content machine for your
website that will start bringing in
organic clicks. If you want to get the
full SOP, again, just comment SEO down
below. And if you want to use any of the
tools that I mentioned in today's video,
like Word Rocket, there will be a link
in today's video. Thanks for watching,
and I'll see you in the next one. Take
care.